80 days half spent in a coma jared
linder fought to survive covet 19. a
year later he's still trying to heal i
had to reason how to walk and
eat everything his partner ashley young
has supported him through it all but
when he was in hospital pandemic
restrictions kept her from his side it
was the toughest thing i've ever had to
go through
just having someone that i love
not like not knowing
if he was gonna be back
or
he was going to make it through and that
stress can have severe outcomes a new
u.s based study has revealed almost 64
percent of relatives of coveted patients
in icu experience significant symptoms
of post-traumatic stress disorder ptsd
in the months that follow
pre-pandemic for families of critical
care patients the number was between 15
and 30 percent that distrust not being
able to be at the bedside and
participate in the care of your loved
one and the way that we know was helpful
the interplay of those things was really
traumatic to people in canada mental
health supports can be difficult to
access with covert related ptsd on the
rise psychologists from two toronto
universities created an online resource
especially for couples going through
covid ptsd is a chronic and very
pernicious disorder so
once people have not recovered from
their ptsd it's unlikely to recover on
its own young says she battled
depression in the months after linder
was admitted i was kind of
having some flashbacks and it was really
making my
my life hard to get through since both
have sought professional help determined
to heal physically
and emotionally jamie morocco global
news toronto